president macron's in tray isn't just
filled with pandemic response so it
certainly has a lot of that there are
curfews proper curfews not the pubs
closing at 10
but actually off the streets don't be
out after 10 o'clock in nine major
french cities
uh this week but even so in a recent
speech the president found time
to draw up new battle lines in the fight
against
islamic extremism in france ayan hursi
ali is a feminist activist former dutch
politician
and she's written in this week's
spectator commending president macron's
speech
that says he should go further she joins
me
now uh i am thank you for being with us
what is it that you liked about what
president macron had said
well i i i loved it that he defined the
problem
as clearly as possible because i think
the failure
of many western leaders at least as far
back as 9 11 2001
was there euphemizing
and obfuscating the problem and calling
it anything but its real name
so i think it takes a great deal of
courage for a leader
on that level to come out and say what
we are
facing is islam is separatism
and so i think that's a fast step um
but then what follows out of that you
know i'm a little skeptical because
i've had angela merkel declare
that multiculturalism was dead
i've at one point even had david cameron
say he was going to take on
these groups and here in the united
states of america i've had president
trump say
he was going to go after the ideological
not just
jihad the the violent islamists
but those who dedicate their time to
poisoning and spreading um these
ideas and we'll see well we'll see what
what he does with it
but what is meant by this word
separatism
can you just explain that i mean to my
knowledge
french muslims are not calling for a
separate
french muslim state
so the thing is if you understand
political islam as a separate philosophy
and it is a philosophy that is
confronting liberal societies and saying
the liberal philosophies that western
societies are based on are corrupt
they're wrong they have to be replaced
with something else
what then these islamists have done is
they have taken advantage of
the immigrant populations and convinced
them
in the case of france for instance that
they
are in a nation-state within a nation
states
and so it's it's it's very clear and i
think it's
it's the right thing for him to do uh to
confront
these islamists but what's the
evidence that the vast majority or even
a substantial minority of french muslim
are islamists
well there's a great deal of evidence
for that that's been building up and
it's not just in france it's in the uk
it's in other european countries and
it's here in america
um the fact that there are islamists uh
there's been plenty of evidence for that
you've had here in india
you've had about as a majority a reason
was but
there are of course you're quite right
there are islamists
in uh in france but what's the evidence
that they represent even a substantial
minority of the french muslim community
substantial enough to plot terrorist
attacks
substantial enough to refuse to learn
the french language and live by french
norms and french standards and there's
a substantial evidence to show us that
there is
what i would say the white french would
regard as an
underclass of people who just refuse to
be or are incapable
of being assimilated into the wider
french
economy and society and
what you know the question then is
why is that happening and i think that
not just the french in this we're using
france as an example but i think that
immigration out of muslim countries uh
into western society uh has yes
brought a somewhat uh culture clash
but leaders have failed constantly and
they failed in four ways they
failed to make it very clear what
islamism is
they've allied with the wrong people
they have failed to
um to
regulates immigration and um there's
been an if you know a failure by
leadership to use the
foreign tools or foreign policy tools
to stop foreign countries from basically
usurping the uh the minorities and and
look at a country like turkey and what
it's doing in france what it's doing in
in germany there's been a failure to use
foreign policy tools to stop
these countries from financing
islamist ideology on european soil
i i know uh and we have to let you go
shortly just two other
quick questions i mean there is
undoubtedly there is an islamic
underclass in france
you see that in some of the suburbs of
the bigger cities they feel excluded
they are almost separate in some ways
but almost every western country has an
underclass like that and it's not
not always islamic in in britain
you could see a white underclass has
developed
in cities the city of glasgow your
husband city
for example in many other parts of the
west you see a black underclass
developed over many years feeling
excluded
i mean given that most french immigrants
are muslim that's what
makes french immigration different from
british or american
or even german immigration they're
mainly muslim
was it not an evil inevitable it may
have nothing to do with islam
that there is uh an islamic underclass
in france
um yes indeed and i think one
so one of the failures i mentioned is
this
failure to regulate immigration give the
muslim communities that are already in
france an opportunity
to go through the process of integration
or assimilation as we call it here in
the united states
and use the tools that
a state has to make it very clear
to those individuals and organizations
that are turning
people's minds away from what it is to
be
french and to to assimilate
and instead brainwashing them into
radical islam
those organizations and those
individuals are groups that they
shouldn't have partnered with and for a
long time they did
and for a long time france and it's not
just france but france has pretty much
outsourced what they thought was the
integration process
to other countries and i think they have
to stop that that is my piece
in the industry
i think there is an awakening now and i
hope that macron really means it and
um that he isn't just saying these
things
to win the election in 2022 um but that
he is dedicated to really doing
something about this problem and setting
an example for the other european
leaders
well we shall see how he follows it up
after this speech uh ayan hersey
thank you for writing your piece of all
the spectator
this week and for joining us from the
hoover institution in california thank
you very much
you